[Music]
in the last video we talked about the
developer experience and how to enhance
the developer experience
based on understanding their needs let's
take it to the next step and understand
how to attract and engage developers
to get started let's take a look at the
digital value chain
most customers who are just embarking on
their digital journey
will start on the right side of the
chain and simply expose the back-end
data assets
the developers will appreciate getting
access to the backend data
until they have to manipulate large
payloads that affect the performance of
their application
that's why it's so important to know
your target audience
moving from right to left the api team
who's charged with exposing the back-end
data for developers
needs to understand the application
developer's needs
using the customer journey and personas
technique to frame up a sample use case
and taking the returns material
authorization process
as an example the api team will need to
determine
how much data is needed to process the
rma if the only data needed is the last
few orders
don't send the entire order history
likewise if only customer name and
address is needed for the rma
then don't send extraneous customer data
that can slow down performance
the digital value chain helps identify
your target audience
most people can relate to the end
customer who uses the mobile apps to
order coffee
purchase products or track deliveries
and most people
overlook the application developer as a
target audience
depending on where you reside on the
digital value chain will depend on who
your target audience is
looking right to left the target
audience for the back end developer is
the api team
the target audience for the developer is
the customer
now take a look at the middle of the
digital value chain
the target audience for the api team is
the developer
who consumes the api product now let's
take a closer look at the developer
the application developer is also known
as the api consumer
the developer community is very diverse
we often hear from companies that
believe a developer community is
restricted
only to internal developers however the
developer community includes internal
developers
partner developers and developers
external to the company
successful communities include all types
of developers and even goes so far as to
treat both
internal and external developers the
same companies with a focus
api product strategy will look outwards
to engage developers
so if your target audience for api
products is your developer community
you will need to actively engage this
community there are three key areas of
focus and developer engagement
one understand the needs of your api
consumers
what do they need to discover apis and
understand them in order to get started
number two market your api product like
you would market any other product or
service
just publishing to a developer
storefront is not enough
you want to drive developers to your
storefront
number three adoption is key to the
success of your program
you will need to define the metrics for
adoption in order to track and measure
your progress
is the number of developers registered
on your developer portal the best
measure of success
or perhaps it's the number of api
products used in production applications
a storefront for developer engagement
has a number of parallel paths to be
thought through
acquisition of developers is key the
developer portal needs to catch the
attention of the developer community
and the developer must know how to get
started with the api products
how do you go about doing this we will
talk about it in the next slide
the developer portal is a storefront for
your api products
therefore the product catalog needs to
be compelling to developers
documentation must be complete and
comprehensive for quick adoption
ensure that the onboarding process is
frictionless the easier you make it for
the developer to register and obtain a
key so they can get started with your
application
is key to fast adoption and finally
don't forget about ongoing maintenance
and support of your storefront
and more importantly your api consumers
if developers have questions on the use
of your api products be sure to provide
a forum to get answers
let's dig into a few of these concepts
follow the 555 rule for developer
acquisition
that is you want to grab their attention
in the first five seconds
build interest in the next five seconds
build a case in the next five minutes
grab their attention by making your
storefront visually stunning
create an api catalog with thorough
documentation
making it easy to understand ensure that
you have a value proposition by making a
compelling case to use your apis
create a getting started page providing
a step-by-step guide on how to work with
your apis
showcase your customer success stories
this can spark ideas for future
innovation
make it easy to get started don't hide
documentation behind registration
make them want to register finally
get them engaged by hosting events like
hackathons
proper documentation will facilitate
onboarding and adoption
putting the effort into complete
documentation up front will improve the
adoption rate
and down the road can reduce the amount
of support needed
note that documentation needs to be
maintained over time
so plan on a team to update content on
your developer portal
make your onboarding process
frictionless by minimizing the amount of
information required to register
we recommend obtaining basic information
needed to identify the developer
such as name email address company and
perhaps a brief description of the
application the developer plans on
creating
the easier you make the registration the
faster you can onboard the developer
self-service on your developer portal is
key to adoption
what does this mean you want to engage
developers by making api products
discoverable to them this doesn't mean
you are giving them the keys to the
kingdom
you can grab their attention by
associating your api products with a
brief description of what they can do
you have the ability to prove api key
requests giving developers
access to your api products in addition
permissions based on the type of
developer can help you tailor the
storefront experience for internal
external or partner developers lastly
provide the capability for developers to
try out the api products on the spot
will go a long way towards faster
adoption a few
years ago i was working with a customer
who was preparing for a demonstration
to allow a patient to update their
prescription on a mobile app
the application developer was
represented by a firm external to my
customer
and based offshore of course in these
situations
there's always a time crunch the
application developer
working with my customer had less than a
week to complete the demo application
in time to showcase it at the annual
hymns conference
yes we were all under the gun to create
the application get access to the api
product
and showcase the self-service features
of the google apigee developer portal
the first step was for the developer to
register on the developer portal and
request an api key
the access to the api product was
granted in the space of a couple hours
then it was all about engaging the
developer through complete documentation
so he knew how to work with the api once
the developer had access to the api
his app development was quick fast
forward to the hims conference for that
year
and my customer was able to showcase a
cool mobile app
allowing patients to update their
current prescriptions
my customer had done this by exposing an
api product giving access to patient
electronic health records
like all well-managed api products this
one required an api
key in order for developers to access
the api
the process of granting or declining the
request for an api key is available
through the developer portal
the developer remarked on the speed of
granting the api
key he mentioned that in the past it had
taken two weeks from the time he
submitted the request
to the acquisition of the api key
acquiring the api key within two hours
of the request
was phenomenal and greatly speeded up
the time to deploy the mobile app
once your storefront is up and running
don't forget to put effort into support
and maintenance
keep your documentation fresh and up to
date provide online forums blogs and
frequently asked questions to reduce the
effort required to support the developer
portal
treat your online storefront like a
retail channel
and spend the resources to keep it a
vibrant community your api consumers are
important
focus on addressing your api consumer
needs with an api first approach
and make engaging with your company
effortless
i will leave you with a few best
practice tips
make your api catalog discoverable make
registration on your developer portal
frictionless ensure that your content is
engaging and up to date
and finally give your developers the
ability to engage with you
by enabling them to test their
application
this will ensure quality rollout for
everyone
i hope you found the topic of developer
engagement engaging
be sure to check out the next video on
adoption strategies
thanks for watching